they will come for you first of all tell
me about this look well I'm wearing them
on and I've put purple in my hair cuz I
figured I have dreadlocks in the movies
purple rocks but yeah this is Salman and
I wanted to be something that was fierce
and sexy and perfect for the manga which
I think think it works now tell me a
little bit about your character and who
she is in the story yeah so I play coy
Yomi and she's one of elitist friends
and goes on the journey with Aleta
and she just supports Aleta from the
first time she meets her and and I think
that's really special to have in a movie
because it's really important for women
to support other women instead of just
being catty sometimes great so she
really just supports Aleta and believes
in her and wants the best for her and
she's there to help on your way in her
journey
it'll be such a spectacle and sets up a
huge world where you kind of want to
know where it's going next where would
you what would you like to see an expert
for your character I mean I would love
to go and fight with Aleta but be by her
side and fight with her that would be
amazing
so we'll see I I I hope that I will get
the chance to do that but that's a dream
congratulations on the cover of Cosmo a
beautiful cover and then we find out
that you've been you and know I've been
swimming us a little bit I mean you know
I think that both of us love each other
very much
and we love our characters together very
much so for us kind of promoting that in
real life was a very hard for us because
you know the love is true there and it
might not be what everyone wants but the
love is true there and I think you can
live someone to put on it
so yeah you know and I love him I always
charmed by him so it is it is mostly
truthful yeah we are we are chomping at
the bit for all the boys we love before
to news you have any update for us
I don't we have a start date but I can't
tell where we are going to start
shooting hopefully pretty soon which
will be awesome and we have a new
character John Ambrose coming in to
rival Noah Peter Pevensie
I don't know who's in that she's been
cast in that role but I'm hopeful that
if someone just as charming as Noah you
guys can swindle so livery we can
swindle all over again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]